i actually don't know where to start
i'm just i'm so furious
and i'm so sad for our country
that they claim to be the party of law
and order
the hypocrisy makes it feel like ash in
my mouth to even
say it because there's no depth no
illegality to which the president will
not stoop
it's astounding
the president has completed what appears
to be
the first raft of pardons
in the lame duck period it's a
a murderer's row of the unpardonable
though an actual row of murderers are
probably
less morally blameworthy than the people
that actually received the pardons
actual war criminals who were
responsible for killing
innocent iraqi citizens including women
and children
ridiculously corrupt politicians like
chris collins and duncan hunter
who were convicted of and were about to
serve extensive prison sentences related
to
insider trading and also embezzling
campaign funds
including but not limited to spending
those campaign funds on extramarital
affairs
actual traitors to this country like
paul manafort
who was a direct conduit to the russians
through constantine kalimnik and oleg
deripaska
and of course the president's cronies
including but not limited to paul
manafort but also roger stone and george
papadopoulos
there's just no end to the depravity
this is unprecedented in its baseness in
its venality
we've just never seen anything like this
in the us
effectively every significant defendant
who refused to cooperate with both the
mueller investigation and also just
maine justice have now been pardoned the
only
exceptions being rick gates and michael
cohen both of whom
actually testified and cooperated
against the president
and this is tin pont dictator banana
republic level corruption
if this seems like comic book villainy
that's because it is this is not a close
case this is not
an issue of red versus blue this is just
pure
flat out corruption and
i guess let's start with the bad news
because on some levels
this is worse than it appears it's not
just
that the morally reprehensible and
actual criminals have been pardoned it's
that
this threatens the very fabric of our
justice system
in part because this is just the opening
act there's no reason to think that
president trump is going to stop
with these pardons in fact there's very
good reason to think that this is just
uh out there to get people tired
that the worst pardons are yet to come
and it's the usual suspects who are the
obvious candidates here
there's no reason to think that the
president will refrain from pardoning
jared kushner pardoning bill barr
pardoning himself
ivanka don jr allen weisselberg the
cfo of the trump organization but
president trump
doesn't have those lines he doesn't feel
shame and he doesn't give a damn
about political norms because what
happened here is a really really big
deal president trump
is pardoning a whole bunch of people who
engaged in criminality in furtherance
of the president's own agenda for his
own campaign
and for other reasons that benefit
president trump personally
because the problem with pardoning
people who engage in actual criminality
for the benefit of the sitting president
if the president is allowed to
pardon and absolve guilt after the fact
there's a million ways for a sitting
president to grift that
let's take an extreme example we often
talk about how the president could
kill someone on fifth avenue but what if
the president hired someone to
kill a political opponent and then
decided to pardon them
or a less extreme example let's call it
stochastic terrorism where the president
just says hey
it'd be really great if someone killed
my main political rival
and then if you actually pardons that
person which potentially the president
could do
well then it just incentivizes actual
murder of political opponents
and while that's obviously extreme
vladimir putin has tried this twice with
his main political rival
alexei navalny and obviously there's a
state law issue here murder is generally
a state law crime so maybe the pardon
wouldn't work but how about this
what if the president intentionally
engaged in all kinds of
campaign finance violations getting
let's say billions of dollars for a
campaign slush fund
and then just pardoned all the people
who engaged in campaign finance
violations for the benefit of the
sitting president
who would then have the benefit of
billions of dollars
of campaign funds if the president can
pardon co-conspirators or pardon those
who engage in criminality at the
president's benefit or just
simply hand out pardons like thank you
cards there is no end to gaming
the system and of course on the other
side of the aisle
so far the republicans have been
absolutely silent
those people who will jump over
themselves
to fawn over this president ben shapiro
mark levin tucker carlson
have said absolutely nothing nothing
and like i said this isn't a close case
this is not this is not my side versus
yours
this is an affront to the actual rule of
law
really at this point only ben sasse has
had the temperature to even
criticize the move saying that this is
rotten to the core
well gee thanks ben thank you for your
service
and by backing those words up with
absolutely no action whatsoever
because there's a lot of damage that's
actually going to keep happening
before january 20th gets here and there
is absolutely nothing
that's in the works to try and stop this
but i
i shouldn't criticize ben sasse at least
he came forward publicly and at least
criticized the president everybody else
seems to be happy just to sit idly by
and silent
and unfortunately it gets worse contrary
to what you
might read on facebook or twitter trump
is almost certainly not going to face
criminal scrutiny
for even pardoning manafort or stone or
anybody else
um absent actual evidence
that there was a an explicit quid pro
quo
between trump and his co-conspirators
there's not going to be criminal
repercussions there's just
not and i don't think uh even
an aggressive attorney general in the
next administration
is going to change that it's an abuse of
power the
uh the guard rail is impeachment and in
when you have a couple of days left in
the trump presidency
impeachment is no real guard rail
whatsoever so
for all intents and purposes it's
unlikely that president trump is going
to face any kind of
real scrutiny as a result of these
actions
and while these are uncharted waters
absent
very strong proof of a separate crime
like extortion
or bribery these pardons are not going
to be declared illegal and it's not even
clear that if you found this separate
criminality that it could be
declared illegal the pardons themselves
and don't expect future
state or federal prosecutions of
manafort or stone
the complications are probably grave
enough
that it's unlikely that they're going to
face
punishment for their actual crimes and
like i said the pardons will continue
the message has been sent
that if you uphold your silence
against who is effectively a mafia dawn
you're going to get a pardon you will be
rewarded
for your service and contravention of
justice
there's no real silver lining there that
die
is cast that norm has been broken and
you can expect that future
administrations are going to take note
if there are no real penalties for
abusing the pardon power this way
and it's ironic too because
traditionally the pardon power has been
grossly under used there are thousands
of people who receive
grossly inappropriate sentences every
year
for all the good that the justice system
does it does a lot of bad too
or at least it's often overzealous
in punishing crimes and there are a lot
of people who are in jail that
arguably should not be and historically
presidents are
much more likely to underuse the pardon
power than they are to
overuse it and to date
we've never seen anything like what
president trump has done
but the what aboutism is strong people
have pointed to the pardoning of mark
rich by president clinton
and that pardon rightfully
sparked bipartisan outrage it sparked
congressional
inquiries this is not to say that
the that particular pardon was in any
way just or correct
people were rightly outraged about it
but this is so much worse there was
and should have been political fallout
for that pardon
but what we're seeing out of the trump
administration is much
much worse it's dozens of individuals
who have a direct connection to the
president
and the pardon is being used in a way
that really does
undermine the rule of law and that's
that's not an exaggeration
because it's going to change the way
that political institutions
use the pardon in the future and it's
not going to get better unless there are
real punishments
now i may be your discount john
krasinski but let me try to give you
some good news here
the first is that paul manafort is not
going to get his townhouses or ostrich
jackets back
uh under ex parte garland a pardon does
not restore offices forfeited
or property or interest vested in others
and consequences of the conviction and
judgment
so at least the mueller investigation
will still have turned a profit
you also probably know that these
pardons
don't really affect state law
prosecutions if there is indeed
a state-based criminality we know
that there are ongoing investigations
particularly in
new york but i counsel you don't hero
worship
the investigators we've been burned time
and time again
that sometimes that's just too much
pressure to put on people like
new york a.g tisch james and manhattan
d.a psy vance
a lot of the criminality that has been
pardoned is purely federal with respect
to
lying to federal prosecutors with
respect to
federal campaign finance violations and
insider trading
it's it's unlikely that a lot of those
crimes have
state law counterparts that could even
be investigated and punished
let alone will be that being said
paul manafort was convicted of numerous
different tax crimes and it's likely
that
new york state has similar state
law tax crimes that he could be charged
with and
even better news recently the new york
legislature
closed a pardoned loophole that would
have prevented prosecution
of someone who receives a pardon when
there is an
ancillary new york state law to
prosecute them under
so while paul manafort was initially
successful in appealing his new york
prosecutions
it's possible that now that new york has
closed this loophole that they can move
forward with prosecuting with him
on state law crimes it's an open
question we'll see what the new york
appellate courts
hold you've also likely heard a lot
about the
fifth amendment with respect to being
pardoned and it is indeed true that
receiving a presidential pardon if you
accept it
does limit the scope under which you can
claim the
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination but it's
unfortunately not
absolute if you face state law liability
then you can still invoke the fifth
amendment privilege
so this will indeed help both
prosecutors and investigators with
respect to
inquiries related to these pardons and
the underlying criminality but
it's not going to help that that much
unfortunately
additionally it's possible that the
pardons themselves
might be crimes maybe
i wouldn't put too much stock in this
but remember that i said that president
trump is not going to face
criminal prosecution for these pardons
well it's possible that he might
there's a slim chance but it's possible
we've seen time and time again
that these members of the trump
administration especially the ones who
have been around since the beginning
are completely inept the doj has already
gotten wind of
a pardon for purchase scheme related to
eliot broidy and it's possible that
there is
an explicit agreement between members of
the trump administration and these
pardons
it's possible that people did attempt or
were successful at buying
a pardon you can look at the list of
people who received pardons and it's not
just
republican cronies and trump cronies
people who actually
engaged in real criminality but also
those who engaged in real criminality
and are also just very very rich people
that don't necessarily fit into this
category of people who are
being rewarded by the president for
their service to the president
people who might have the means to
actually
buy a pardon and if
those explicit agreements are out there
it's possible that
the the agreement was memorialized and
the emails or
documents will leak that the
attorney-client privilege
will be violated because of the crime
fraud exception
uh and someone might talk after
trump can't actually pardon people
anymore if there is a
actual clear quid pro quo between
president trump or other members of his
administration
and the granting of a pardon
it could conceivably give rise to
independent criminality
and potential punishment that's a big if
but hopefully this ends the discussion
about
future prosecutions or at least future
investigations
past pardons have led to congressional
investigations
and this one absolutely
needs investigations if not outright
prosecutions
and if not prosecutions on a federal
level then prosecutions on a state law
level and hopefully this represents the
absolute
zenith of presidential power
at the moment the president has never
been
more powerful the president receives
almost unchecked power with respect to
executive
power and executive privilege but these
actions are
so far beyond the pale
that i hope it forces
the citizens and members of congress to
actually act
to actually put some real checks and
balances and to scale back some of the
power that has been
granted from congress to the presidency
make no mistake this is a political
rubicon
this is every bit as bad as it appears
in some ways we're lucky that they've
been
so ham-fisted about this because there's
no hiding it this isn't 4d
chess this is just plain
cronyism and corruption and it's going
to get worse before it gets better
just don't let it wear you down but
americans did their part
and they voted overwhelmingly to send
president trump packing
we could be looking down the barrel of
four more years of this but luckily he
will be leaving office
but there's one last thing to do which
is that we must demand
of the future administrations that they
not let these pardons
go unchecked that they cannot allow this
criminality to go
unchecked we assume that the president's
pardon power is near universal
but so much of this is debating how many
angels can dance on the head of a pin
presidential pardons have rarely been
challenged we don't know what the
supreme court would have said
if the forward pardon of nixon had been
challenged or the iran-contra
pardons had been challenged and we don't
know what a supreme court would do with
these current raft of pardons and we
don't know all of the information about
these particular pardons
was there an explicit quid pro quo is
there independent criminality about
these particular parts
the american people have a right to know
that particular information
which is why we must demand that the
next administration either through the
attorney general
or a special prosecutor investigate the
issuance of
these pardons investigate the underlying
criminality itself if there is
remaining criminality out there
charge them indict them test the
sufficiency of the pardon test the
breath
of the pardons and let's see what the
supreme court has to say
and if the supreme court upholds the use
of these pardons then so be it we can
demand a constitutional amendment or
other congressional means to put limits
on this power
because that's what americans deserve we
fought a war
to throw off the rule of a king and
these pardons come
as close as americans ever have to
reverting back to tyranny
because as bad as these pardons are
next time will be worse